[Music]
hey day
day
watch we got work to do
yeah i'm playing world of warships
world of warships is the free-to-play
naval strategy game where you command
the most iconic and famous warships from
world war 1 and world war ii recreate it
with stunning detail and accuracy build
your fleet while participating in
various game types while upgrading your
ship's arsenal along the way new players
who sign up using my link below will
receive an exclusive starter pack to get
you up and running quickly by receiving
seven days premium time one million
credits 300 dubloons and the tier v
premium ship the exeter so what are you
guys waiting for start sinking ships
with world of warships by hitting the
description below and getting your
freebies
all right so obviously i'm uh way past
the actual launch time of this card uh
obviously we're talking about the rx
6600 xt the newest offering for the
entry level actually i want to call it
entry level i mean they'll probably come
out with a 6500 xt also just like we had
a 5500 xt
but this is kind of their more
affordable pricing for rdna 2 which
obviously we'll talk about here in a
second i'm late to this review because i
wanted to kind of see how the launch is
going to go i wanted to see uh what the
inventory was going to look like also
too i wasn't willing to put the work i
was doing on the build behind me here on
hold
even further to get a review of a fairly
mediocre card done now i saw the reviews
i saw i watched a few of the reviews i
read some of the written articles and i
feel like that there was this a really
negative
um welcome for the 6600 xt and that
really got me kind of thinking about
this objectively in that obviously we
are in a very interesting
difficult time to be
a pc diy
builder building it yourself right now
there are just probably tens of
thousands if not more hundreds of
thousands maybe systems that are sitting
there new built and waiting for a
graphics card to be put in there and i
think we live in a time right now when
when people are desperate to where they
will put just about anything that can
generate an image above 60 fps in their
system just to complete it and then
later on if things ever normalize or
come back to normal which is now
based on the latest news looking like
potentially 2023 before we see things
start to look normal again i think
people will just put any any old pos
that they can in their system just to
get it up and running
but i want to make sure that we look at
this objectively and fairly in that what
is the card designed to do is it doing
what it's designed to do
and is it does it have any sort of value
so those are kind of like the three
prongs that people's at least we kind of
try and take a look at around here so
without boring you about a bunch of the
specs because you guys have obviously
seen all of the specs um it is obviously
a very very cut down version of our dna
too in fact it is less than one quarter
of the die size of a 6800 xt if you were
to basically put four of these next to
each other like in a square it would not
still cover the entire die of a 1600 xt
so it's clearly cut down it does have rt
accelerators in it however i'm going to
tell you right now before we look at the
charts that i did not even bother
testing any sort of ray tracing with
this card because i do not feel that the
fps trade-off or the fps hit that you're
going to see on a card that already is
as shaved down as this is
is worth
the prettiness of ray tracing if you
want to take a pretty screenshot or
something that's fine turn it on
obviously who cares at that point you're
only looking at one frame that's not
moving um but yeah i don't think a card
like this
or even something like a 3600 or a 360
ti or anything like that should ever be
considered a retracing card um with all
that said
um it's an eight gigabyte card which in
2021 is starting to become the limiting
factor of a lot of titles especially
with titles that have ray tracing turned
on or any sort of high resolution um
textures and stuff now like you're
seeing in in many of these games an 8
gigabyte frame buffer although gddr6
and the faster infinity fabric built
into amd's rdna 2 is still probably
going to show its
lifespan being shorter now with games
that are coming out in the near future
so anyway with that said
we compared it to
the rtx 3060 ti not the 3060 because
this is much closer to the price of a
360 ti and depending on the model um
even more expensive than some 360 ti's
and the 5700 xt so we compared it to the
previous generations card that comes in
at about the same price as this again
speaking in msrp i
i'll talk about pricing in a second
let's just go ahead and look at the
charts you can see how compared to last
gen's one tier higher card and nvidia's
current offering at roughly the same
price point
[Music]
so
so unlike the 6800 xt and the 6900xt
which gave very compelling performance
uh competition to nvidia's offerings of
the 3080 and 3090 the 6600 xt fell short
of the 3060 ti in
pretty much every single use case we
threw at it now
we didn't use any production type uh
benchmarks for this card because i also
don't think the 6600xt is a production
card it's just straight up 1080p gaming
which is what amd was targeting and to
be fair you know i started the test
by only doing 1080p but then i started
looking at how high the fps was in
certain titles at 1080p and i went well
there's no reason why this card couldn't
also be considered a 1440p gaming card
which obviously it's very capable of now
remember all of our tests are performed
with the highest settings or near
highest settings depending on the title
some titles to the highest settings turn
on things like rt shadows and whatnot so
we disabled that sort of functionality
we also had no dlss turned on for 360 ti
so there was no sort of proprietary
technology of like
fidelity fx type function turned on with
amd that was all off and then dlss
turned off with 360 ti so it was just
brute force methods of gaming to see how
the cores compare
now the 3060 ti depending on the model
that you go with is about 399
yes i'm
obviously aware of how screwed up
pricing is right now but you if you live
near best buy and you're lucky you can
get a 30 a 30 60 ti for 399
the 5700 xt
is a
439 card at the time that it launched
remember when that card launched you
could get them for that price because we
didn't have the extreme chip shortage
the extremely high ethereum mining
happening and the extremely high demand
of a global pandemic happening causing
the supply and demand to go completely
flip-flopped so
this card right now the red devil 6600
xt and the 5700 xt red devil same model
card right in terms of the naming this
is actually only ten dollars cheaper at
429 now yes this card actually was
available for 429 on newegg and it was
available for 429 at micro center in
fact when i started filming this video
they still uh had a couple of models
available at micro center uh assuming a
couple a couple of these cards available
at microcenter with
shipping uh
i think some by now was actually they
already refilled the stock so powercolor
was very very communicative prior to
this launching we will have plenty we
will have lots we will have lots there
will be plenty at lunch and then they
sent another email going i guess we
underestimated how badly people wanted
this card we have more coming soon it's
like you would think by now you would
stop making a statement like we will
have plenty have you not learned
have you just not been watching but
anyway i i digress
i just didn't even respond to those
emails because i was like
uh
okay bro
so this leads us to the current
situation if you're running something
like a 5700 xt and you're looking at
this card as being some sort of an
upgrade because it has more cus and yada
yada and it has rt core or rt
accelerators and whatnot it's a side
grade as you can see on the charts it
beats the 5700 xt by a few fps on
certain titles and gets beat by a few
fps and other titles and depending on
the resolution might be beat the 5700 xt
in 1440 but it might lose in 1080. it's
just it's such a ping pong match that
it's a side grid and if you have a 5700
xt rdna one card there is zero incentive
to try and find this card if you have no
graphics card whatsoever it might be
worth trying to find but again a 1080p
target at 429
is a really stupid value there's no
value there but that's because
manufacturers have realized we could
sell a polished turd for 429 dollars if
they can plug it into their system and
get their system running
and unfortunately that's where we are
with a lot of manufacturers right now
not giving you any sort of performance
uplift at
a perfor a cost decrease
that's why the 30 series cards were so
would look so good on paper before the
prices went crazy because you had a
massive fps uplift at a dramatic
price per fps decrease but if you look
at the 5700 xt and that's why we compare
pricing tiers and not
naming tiers the 6600 xt
is the same fps per dollar essentially
if we compare msrps there's no real
uplift here which makes it just putting
lipstick on a pig of a curtain situation
that we have right here because you're
not getting anything more for your money
you're just now grateful that you can
buy anything and that's a terrible place
to be as a consumer i don't think the
card is terrible i think it's capable of
of
giving you excellent 1080p gaming
and very good 1440p gaming at over 60
fps in just about everything we tested
except some i think metro exodus might
have been the only one that was right
around i think it was like 58 fps or
something like that it's it's just kind
of
lackluster really there's just nothing
exciting about it i don't think it's as
bad as people make it out to be but i
think that's because people are really
jaded at this current time where we
expected so much this generation from
both families and then we live in a
situation now where you're just happy to
get anything that boots
it just leaves not much left to talk
about the other thing that kind of sucks
is if you look at the pricing on newegg
this card looks like a hero card because
it's the second cheapest card there is
for the 6600 xt and this is before
scalping really kind of starts
rearing its ugly head because as soon as
things were available at msrp which
these cards were and we'll talk about
pricing in a sec on some of the other
models as soon as those are gone and
sold out that's when the price starts to
go up if you can buy it for a near msrp
the scalping opportunity is is not there
now that they're sold out we're probably
going to see a gradual increase in
pricing
which is going to suck the only card
cheaper than this one was an xfx card at
which again is the the founders edition
pricing which you can still buy at best
buy if you're lucky for the 30 60 ti
which beats it in every single category
so my point is if you were to walk into
a store
and you can see a 30 30-60 ti on the
shelf if it's there and yeah they are
starting to happen now you i i am seeing
alerts of inventory in stock at various
micro centers and best buys it's just
it's taking time now for the pricing to
come back down and the longer they sit
on the shelves the more price will come
back down
if you see a 360 ti and you see a 6600
xt
there's absolutely no reason to get the
6600 there's just not
the problem is
because there's no real reference like
amd available card for this one pricing
is all over the place because when i
went on newegg to research the pricing
this card launched at and because one of
the other promises that power color gave
me is that there were going to be so
many available on launch day that
scalping wasn't going to be an issue
that's the other like oh my god how cute
that's a bold that's a bold bold play
cotton let's see how it plays out right
or bold move cotton whatever
it doesn't matter it was a stupid
strategy
because i i have a feeling that pricing
is going to go up however
429 is what they sold out on newegg you
can find 6600 xt's at nearly 600.
not scalped
that's what the msrps were setting them
at or the manufacturers were sending
their msrps at depending on msi card
gigabyte cards sapphire cards xfx cards
and depending on the model so what we
essentially have right here is the
supply and demand situation has made
everyone just completely fed up with the
fact that manufacturers have caught on
to hey like i said earlier they will buy
a polished turd if it
will finish their system so it's
essentially like trying to do price
comparison right now for us as reviewers
is like trying to do surgery with a
shotgun and be precise about it it's
impossible because everyone is just all
over the place we've got 300 swings
between this card and the most expensive
6600xt i could find and you know what's
sad about that the performance between
them is very minimal the performance
difference
so i went ahead and did this review
because you know obviously if you walk
into a store and there's one available
you need to know what you're getting
yourself into my recommendation
360 ti outperforms this in the same
price category the problem is 360 tis
have been scalp now for so long the
pricing trying to find a 360 ti
at the price this was available at is
impossible as of this video when we were
searching they were anywhere between 800
to 950 for 360 ti which is absolutely
stupid but if you can walk into a store
and get this card for the price it's
advertised at 429 then obviously it's a
better buy over a 360 ti i've never had
to make so many caveat but but but in a
video about pricing as i have this one
sound off in the comments below if you
guys even cared about the 6600 xt is it
a card you would put in your system or
are you one of those buyers that i just
said that would literally put a turret
in your computer if it allows you to
play games today thanks for watching
guys as always